كبير ومديري المنتجات في جوجل جاك كراوزك
قال ان الشركه بدات الاصدار العام لروبوت
الدردشه الخاص بها بورد سعيا لجذب
المشتركين والحصول على ردود فعل على
البرنامج الذي تخوض به غمار المنافسه في
عالم الذكاء الاصطناعي مع تشات جي بي تي
المدعوم من مايكروسوفت واضاف كراوزك انه
سيتسنى للمستخدمين في الولايات المتحده
وبريطانيا في بادئ الامر الانضمام الى
قائمه الانتظار للوصول الى هذا التطبيق
وفي عرض توضيحي اظهر كراوزك كيف ينشئ
نصوصا باكملها في لحظه بطريقه تختلف عن
تشات جي بي تي الذي يكتب الاجابات كلمه
بكلمه ويشتمل ايضا على
مميزه تعرض ثلاثه اصدارات مختلفه او
مسودات لاي اجابه وبها زر ابحث في جوجل
اذا رغب المستخدم في الحصول على نتائج من
على الانترنت لاي سؤال يريد معرفه اجابته